bonjour bienvenue dans file echo
l'émission économie qui revient sur
l'actualité locale on commence tout de
suite avec les grandes lignes de cette
émission cinquante huit mille huit cents
c'est le nombre de personnes sans emploi
dans le département retour dans un
instant sur les chiffres du chômage de
novembre les français sont de plus en
plus nombreux à revendre leurs cadeaux
de noël à maurepas un magasin d'achat et
de vente d'occasion profite même de
cette période de l'année pour gonfler
son chiffre d'affaires
nous reviendrons également sur les
moments forts de cette année 2013 que
s'est il passé au niveau économique
réponse dans notre dossier de la semaine
et maintenant que 2014 a commencé nous
nous intéresserons aux perspectives pour
les entreprises cette année nous
recevons sur notre plateau bertrand de
craie bonsoir shore c'est le président
du medef dans les îles ville on vous
retrouve dans un instant et avant cela
on regarde ce qu'il s'est passé dans
l'actualité cette semaine
les chiffres du chômage pour le mois de
novembre sont tombées la semaine
dernière comme je l'indiquais dans les
titres on compte 58 1800 personnes
inscrites à pôle emploi en catégorie à
un chiffre en hausse de 0,6 pour cent
par rapport à fin octobre 340 personnes
de plus mais surtout une hausse de 8%
sur l'année c'est plus que la hausse
établie en ile de france ou même dans le
pays les personnes les plus touchées les
seniors le nombre de personnes sans
emploi de plus de 50 ans a augmenté de
11 % en 2013
cette information qui vient d'être
publiée par le site contribuables point
org un site de contribuables associés
qui sont intéressés aux dépenses des
communes dans les yvelines et l'encours
se classe à la première position dans
les villes les moins dépensière de sa
catégorie population une note de 19 sur
20 suis dit suivi par don du chéné et de
houille trois autres villes de même
catégorie sont jugées beaucoup moins
beaucoup trop dépensière avec une note
de zéro sur vingt il s'agit là de
mantes-la-jolie les mureaux et vélizy
pour l emploi c'est une bonne nouvelle
qui se confirme la ville avait déjà été
classé en 2006 comme étant la ville la
mieux gérée des yvelines par le magazine
challenge
etes-vous de ceux qui revendent leurs
cadeaux de noël les français en tout cas
le font de plus en plus nous sommes
rendus à maurepas dans un dépôt vente au
lendemain de noël ce magasin réalise son
plus gros chiffre d'affaires un
reportage réalisé avec olivier
maniscalco un client vient de me
revendre ce
je pense que quand il l'a acheté il
s'est trompé de consoles son neveu à
part la console wii il a une console ps3
je vais racheter 35 euros et 9 savons 59
secondes
selon un récent sondage opinionway six
français sur dix seraient aujourd'hui
prêts à revendre leurs cadeaux de noël
c'est 10 % de plus que l'an passé les
mentalités évoluent et ce sont les
enseignes spécialisées qui se frottent
les mains dans ce magasin à maurepas on
rachète aux particuliers du matériel
plus ancien mais aussi les cadeaux reçus
au pied du sapin qui hier 26 décembre
était le le jour des consoles de jeu on
a racheté est quasiment une vingtaine de
consoles de jeux pour des gens qui ont
une nouvelle console qui son humour à
vendre leurs anciennes consoles ou qui
nous ont vendu la console car il avait
déjà et on a racheté près de 200 jeux
vidéo est fière aujourd'hui la
possession d'un produit est moins
importante que l'utilisation d'un
produit ce qui intéresse les gens c'est
d'avoir le jeu dont tout le monde parle
s'en servir allez à la fin puis le
revendre pour acheter un nouveau
aujourd'hui on consomme le produit on ne
possède plus et contrairement aux délais
que les sites spécialisés d'internet
peuvent imposer ici l'achat est immédiat
pour ce faire il suffit d'être majeur
est de présenter une pièce d'identité en
salles de ventes les produits sont
ensuite testés par des techniciens avant
qu'acheteurs et vendeurs tentent de
trouver un accord sur le prix le
paiement se fait en cash jusqu'à 750
euros
sinon ce sera par chèque à l'instar des
bijoux et des métaux précieux comme la
loi l'exigé
toute l'année je pense que c'est
intéressant de venir ici c'est pas
spécialement les fêtes temps en temps je
viens je revends aussi des trucs voilà
pour débarrasser
envie de changement c'est un bon moyen
d'avoir de l'argent en espèces tout de
suite au lieu de les jeter même si les
chiffres d'affaires restent
confidentielles la période de noël est
clairement une période faste pour les
enseignes spécialisées les articles
rencontrant le plus de succès restent
les produits dits technologiques fin
décembre une centaine de consoles et 300
jeux vidéo ont ainsi été vendus
plus de quarante téléphone portable et
une dizaine de tablettes numériques
la fédération des yvelines du secours
populaire a organisé une croisière sur
la seine pour fêter la fin d'année
étaient conviés 50 personnes âgées
isolées une belle initiative permise par
les dons au micro d'olivier maniscalco
le président national du secours
populaire nous explique que les dons
viennent de plus en plus du secteur
privé
nous avons maintenant un réseau de
partenaires solidaires c'est à dire
qu'il ya des entreprises qui ont décidé
de verser de l'argent d'offrir des
moyens ou strobo puller alors comme nous
sommes une association indépendante
il faut qu'on rame c'est le moment de le
dire puisque on est sur un bateau mais
on a des résultats et on peut offrir de
cette croisière de c'est le moment de
bonheur pour les personnes âgées
et parmi ces entreprises de nombreuses
entreprises yvelinoise le carrefour des
saint quentin en yvelines a par exemple
offert 1000 euros pour cette sortie sur
le bandeau qui s'affiche vous trouverez
toutes les coordonnées pour vous aussi
faire un don
une galerie photos virtuelles c'est ce
que propose deux jeunes entrepreneurs
les internautes peuvent y acheter leurs
photographies d'art à vélizy 2 les
fondateurs de pics au pôle it and expose
quelques unes des oeuvres proposées et
expliquent leur concept store nous avons
rencontré des images d'elodie moines
dans la galerie marchande de vélizy 2 ce
magasin éphémère propose des
photographies d'art un espace à 6 réduit
mais l'ensemble de la collection est
visible via ses tablettes un nouveau
concept de vente 2.0 vous avez accès en
fait à une visualisation de chacun des
formats et de chacune définition grâce à
l'application par exemple si vous
souhaitez un petit format classique me
soumaré lui fait cadre vous pouvez le
voir ici et bien sûr voir le rendu que
cela donnera chez vous la galerie
virtuelle propose dix mille photographie
du monde entier un jury d'experts les
sélectionne avec les deux fondateurs
paul henri et romain leur édition est
limitée de 50 à 500 exemplaires pour des
prix oscillant entre 29 et 450 euros la
société a été lancé en octobre 2012
alors que ces jeunes entrepreneurs
étaient encore étudiants rentrent tous
les échanges à l'étranger on est
étudiant moi j'avais passé beaucoup de
temps à shanghai mais en arrivant à
reims la ville dans laquelle on a étudié
je souhaitais découvrir un appartement
d'une d'une photo une belle photo de la
skyline schengen et j'ai rien trouvé sur
internet mais dans les magasins de déco
et je me suis rendu compte de deux
choses que j'étais loin d'être le seul à
chercher les photographies de lieux
particuliers qui avaient du sens pour
moi photo d'art pour les cours
intérieures et l'autre chose c'est qu'il
avait énormément de photographes de
talent prêt à exposer à vendre des
photographies de grande qualité de tout
c'est grandir sans expérience
professionnelle romain et paul henry se
sont fait épauler par des accélérateurs
d'entreprise leur coach les ont aidé à
lever 230000 euros deux fois le mois
dernier
prochaine étape être présent
physiquement dans les grandes villes de
france il reste d'ici là accessible en
ligne et jusque fin bien vélizy
et
c'est maintenant l'heure de l'entretien
nous recevons sur ce plateau bertrand de
craie je n'ose pas vous êtes président
départemental du medef et vous êtes avec
nous pour nous parler des perspectives
de 2014 alors juste un mot tout d'abord
quand même sur l'année qui vient de
s'écouler qu'est ce qu'il ya à retenir
coûte et y ait pas de fait tellement de
grands faits marquants à celle où il ya
quand même eu l'élection du président
pierre gattaz
si au début de l'année 2013 on a quand
même eu la signature de l'ani qui note
pour moi une
nouvelle étape de la démarche de
dialogue social et on l'est on a réussi
à s'entendre et bâtir quelque chose
ce qui est très marquant aussi c'est que
j'ai pu causer sur le terrain c'est une
perte de confiance quand même de la part
des chefs d'entreprise qui ont
l'impression d'être incompris kra z
charge ne pas avoir est un peu les boucs
émissaires et ça c'est très marquant on
pourrait noter aussi que pour acquis que
le nos gouvernants sont fins aperçu
qu'il y avait une crise qu'il était dur
il ya donc une prise de conscience alors
côté chiffres on a parlé des chiffres du
chômage au niveau de la croissance il
faut encore attendre les derniers
chiffres du quatrième trimestre mais le
cd annonce une croissance de 0 2% en
2013 en 2014 elle prévoit une croissance
de 1% alors ce n'est pas forcément
toujours tenu finalement au bout du
compte mais est ce que c'est le signe
d'une embellie
je me garderai de tout commentaire sur
les chiffres de la croissance
on s'aperçoit que c'est sûr ça devient
de celle aléatoire et que ceux qui font
ces prévisions ont du mal à les tenir
moi je crois
je crois qu'il faut qu'il faut pour
sortir de cette crise s'engager
collectivement ça va dans le sens
d'ailleurs de ce qu'a proposé pierre
gattaz quand il a le 18 novembre dernier
demandez au président république de
créer un pacte de confiance que la
croissance parce que c'est vraiment
cette confiance qui redonnait et
redonner aux entrepreneurs redonner
population permettra de générer la
croissance des actes tout le démo alors
à priori le président françois hollande
aurait entendu cette cette demande il a
annoncé lors de ses voeux la création
d'un pacte de responsabilité
donc c'est pas encore en détails ce
qu'il contiendra mais il indique il
promet en tout cas au chef d'entreprise
je cite - de charges sur le travail
moins de contraintes sur leurs activités
et en même temps une contrepartie plus
dans gauche et plus de dialogue social
c'est c'est finalement ce que réclamait
votre présidence tout à fait quand j'ai
écouté moi j'aime la presse aussi je
lisais avant à vendredi ce plateau si je
m'arrête ou simple discours présidentiel
je ne peux dire que mon adhésion donné
que notre adhésion c'est exactement ce
que nous demandons nous demandons une
baisse des dépenses publiques c'est ce
qui a été également annoncées
nous devons dépenser moins pour réduire
déficits et pouvoir à terme baisser les
impôts seulement des pouvoirs publics
ont peu cuits social que nous demandons
moins de charges des entreprises pour
embaucher plus je vous rappelle que nous
engageons le medef par pierre gattaz à
la voix de pierre gattaz s'est dit que
nous pouvons créer un million d'emplois
en cinq ans effectivement donc quand le
président nous dit écoute va baisser vos
charges et en contrepartie nous allons
embaucher nous pour 4 d'accord y
souscrire je vais peut-être mais il me
faudra la déclaration de vos présidents
ont quand même puisque c'est la qualité
de presse qui est qui et d'aujourd'hui
pierre gattaz dodik les colis française
peut se relever et la création d'emplois
peut repérer notre pays cependant
engager sans tarder les réformes
indispensables
le medef est prêt à participer à
s'impliquer activement pour bâtir
concrètement le pacte annoncé par le
président république il faut cependant
avancer rapidement car il ya urgence
sur les bancs de pierre gattaz alors il
ne manque tout les actes autre point
positif la réforme de la formation
professionnelle qui doit avoir lieu très
prochainement vous avez trouvé portait
déjà ce projet vous avez trouvé un
accord mi décembre tout à fait le 13 mai
c'est un des points les points forts
pour cette nouvelle année c'est cette
importance est important parce qu'on a
on a remplacé
un dif parra cpe alors 17 à 3 10 la
formation qui était dont le salarié
perdait le bénéfice quand il tombe au
chômage d'entreprise alors l'ofppt avec
le compte personnel de france edf il va
pouvoir accumuler des points et le gérer
lui-même
il va y avoir puisque vous savez que
c'est à peu près 0 9% masse salariale
c'est un système est aujourd'hui pour
les petites entreprises donc moins de 10
salariés une baisse des cotisations de
cette balle passe à 0,55
pour les autres si vous n'êtes pas mais
je dirais et ça c'est une parole
entrepreneurs la formation
c'est un investissement n'est pas
d'accord oui oui mais la cgem a des
raisons que je ne comprends pas
le nom comprenant pas parce que la
formation c'est vraiment la faire de
tous et moi là je vous parle en tant que
chef d'entreprise de pme
investir ce n'est pas une dépense
d'investissement investir à la plus fort
mais pas une dépense c'est un
investissement alors ce qu'est ce que
vous réclamez surtout vous là pour cette
nouvelle année c'est une baisse du coût
du travail tout à fait donc si c'est le
grand message que vous avez diffusé le
cic le fameux crédits d'impôt pour la
compétitivité et l'emploi permettent de
bénéficier déjà d'une baisse de 4% de la
masse salariale seulement sur les
salaires supérieurs à 2 5 fois le smic
un taux qui serait porté à 6% pour cette
année l'équivalent de 10 milliards
d'euros selon vous pour cette
pour mettre en place dix ans cette
mesure ça risque tout de même d'être
compliqué c'est positif toute la mise en
place et complète on va pas bouder c'est
une mesure c'est une bonne mesure mais
une demie à femme à moitié bonne
pourquoi le fait qu'on ait une réduction
de nos charges pour les salaires
inférieurs à 2 2 fois ni le smi qui sont
les bas salaires c'est très bien
toutefois c'est un crédit d'impôt donc
ça n'a pas d'actions immédiates il faut
il faut attendre un an pour en jouer
alors on nous dit ce qu'il voyait des
mécanismes qui existent à domicile qui
sont en difficulté en création il faut
monter un dossier mais mais là encore
une fois il faut je réclame des mesures
simples il faut bien simple il faut
prendre conscience que notre pays est un
pays de paix mais de tpe que le chef
d'entreprise il est souvent au travail
avec ses salariés et tous ces mécanismes
compliqués font qu'il
il les applique pas forcément il épouse
il les comprend pas tout de suite et
surtout quand ils ont une répercussion à
un nom
reste
que la hausse de la tva que pardon le
crédit d'impôt sera financée en partie
par la hausse de la tva ce sera un sujet
dont on évoquera notamment la semaine
prochaine on peut noter qu'il passera
tout de même de 7 à 10% pour l'artisanat
l'hôtellerie la restauration ce que vous
indiquiez en dehors du plateau c'est que
finalement la tva n'est pas si forte que
ça en france oui fait le taux de tva -
le tour qu'on monte avait alors pas du
tout à 20
on le croit avoir lu récemment
sur une étude que le taux moyen au
niveau la plus dure au pnd pays 21 donc
voyez on n'est pas la france n'est pas
hors-jeu quoi la danse et de ce taux de
cotisation on en parlera plus plus
longuement la semaine prochaine un
dernier point peut-être sur le travail
le dimanche une information qui est paru
aujourd'hui la cgt fo
tandis qu'elle ne ratifierait pas
l'accord proposé par décret mardi par le
gouvernement et qui propose donc aux
magasins de bricolage d'ouvrir le
dimanche jusqu'en juillet 2015 c'est une
grosse erreur pour nous c'est un combat
d'un autre âge c'est ce et de la
compréhension c'est d'algues au total de
ce que veulent les français les
françaises aujourd'hui d'abord et je
suis ouvert le dimanche matin
que sur le volontariat
vous êtes des populations des
contreparties d'ailleurs
je vous disais un plateau une mère de
famille qui travaille peut préférer
avoir le mercredi de livres toute la
journée pour s'occuper de ses enfants et
éviter de les mettre en garderie et
d'avoir des compos supplémentaires et
travailler le dimanche quand son mari la
semepa gesca lhc bratton de quoi je
parle on a des étudiants qui ne
demandent que ça travailler le dimanche
en plus donc et toute façon ces bâtisses
sur le volontariat donc il n'y a pas
d'obligation on aura dans tous les cas
très prochainement le texte de loi je
vous remercie beaucoup en tout cas
d'aval et sur notre plateau pour ce
début d'année et on espère du coup que
le concret arrivera très bientôt nous
espérons aussi on passe maintenant décès
la semaine
après avoir parlé des perspectives pour
les entreprises en ce début d'année je
vous propose de revenir sur les moments
forts de 2013 que s'est il passé au
niveau économique dans les yvelines
réponse avec notre dossier la semaine a
réalisé avec romain respini
retour sur une année chargée en
actualité économique
la crise est toujours bien présente en
france et cela se ressent tout d'abord
sur l'emploi dans les yvelines 58 mille
huit cents personnes sont au chômage une
hausse de 8% depuis le début de l'année
les annonces de licenciements se sont
multipliés petites et grosses
entreprises aucune n'était pas renié en
janvier le constructeur automobile
renault annonce un plan de compétitivité
gel des salaires en 2013 suppression de
7500 postes d'ici 2016 est temps de
travail augmenter les ouvriers de
l'usiné de flins monte au créneau en
mars un accord est trouvé les syndicats
acceptent les conditions en contrepartie
renault s'engage à augmenter les
productions et à maintenir l'activité
des sites aujourd'hui l' usine de flins
produit entre autres la zoé une voiture
électrique vendus depuis mars un atout
écologique mais aussi économique
treize mille 700 euros les salariés de
virgin ont eu moins de chance avec la
montée du e-commerce l enseigne connaît
de grandes difficultés financières en
janvier elles déposent le bilan le
tribunal de commerce rejette toutes les
offres de reprise virgin est liquidée le
17 juin conséquence ses 26 magasins en
ferme dont celui de montigny le
bretonneux les produits sont bradés le
magasins dévalisés
une quarantaine de personnes travaillent
toujours à montigny le magasin bricorama
fermé ses portes fin décembre la chaîne
de bricolage met en avant des
difficultés financières dues à son
interdiction d'ouvrir le dimanche
contrairement aux enseignes leroy merlin
et castorama fin 2012 une décision de
justice l'avait contraint fermé 32
magasins depuis elles dénoncent une
concurrence déloyale bricorama porte
plainte un échec au niveau judiciaire
hier mais la question du travail
dominical est mis sur la table face à la
grogne populaire le gouvernement a
promis une modification de la loi pour
2014 en attendant il autorise tous les
magasins de bricolage sans exception à
ouvrir le dimanche une satisfaction pour
bricorama qui n'a pas ouvert pour autant
son établissement de montigny les 23
salariés ont été reclassés dans d'autres
magasins du groupe au début de l'année
le groupe eads annonce une
restructuration et un plan d'économies
global de 200 millions d'euros eads
devient en 2014 airbus groupe les
salariés se montrent inquiets sur leur
sort notamment sur le site d'elancourt
il refuse le projet de cession de la
filiale cassidian tests et services en
décembre la direction du groupe annonce
la suppression de 5800 poste dont 1700
en france sont concernées les filiales
cassidian et astrium présente à
elancourt mais aussi aux mureaux areva
connais aussi une restructuration le
groupe cède sa filiale euriware dont le
siège est à guyancourt à capgemini
autres établissements en difficulté
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines proche de la cessation de
paiement il manquait quatre millions
d'euros pour boucler le budget 2013
enfin ikea connu des difficultés n'ont
pas financière mais judiciaire ikea
france dont le siège est basé à plaisir
et mise en examen ses dirigeants sont
accusés d'avoir espionné leurs salariés
face à ces difficultés le gouvernement a
mis en place des mesures pour relancer
l'emploi il cherche notamment à
combattre le chômage des jeunes et des
seniors et pour cela il créé en février
le contrat de génération ce dernier vise
à favoriser l'embauché d'un jeune le
maintien d'un seigneur et la
transmission de savoir-faire inter
générationnel pour valoriser cette
mesure le président en personne s'est
rendu fin avril aux mureaux il y a
rencontré lydia et marie première
signataire de ce contrat dans le
département nous les avions retrouvé
dans leur antre versaillaise quelques
mois plus tard françois hollande lance
les emplois francs il offre ainsi une
prime de 5000 euros à toute entreprise
embauchant un jeune issus de quartiers
populaires
le ministre de la ville françois lamy
annonce en septembre que saint quentin
en yvelines fait partie des 30
agglomérations françaises concernées par
cette mesure mais 2013 est aussi marqué
par des mesures gouvernementales
impopulaire la modification du statut
d'auto-entrepreneur réclamé par les
syndicats partisans secteur du bâtiment
en tête provoquent des remous au
mouvement des pigeons les défenseurs de
ce statut lance la fronde des poussins
une pétition est lancée dans le
département comme dans toute la france
les deux parties opposent leurs
arguments la ministre de l'artisanat
tente un compromis en limitant les
possibilités du statut d'auto
entrepreneur sans le supprimer en
septembre la rentrée politique est
chargée en annonces réforme de la
fiscalité choc de simplification réforme
des retraites le patronat profite de
l'université du medef organisé à jouy en
josas pour faire entendre leurs
revendications les syndicats de
travailleurs quant à eux descendent dans
la rue pour manifester contre la réforme
des retraites nous les avions suivi
jusqu'à paris un mois plus tard les
bonnets rouges s'oppose à l'écotaxe
cette mesure finançant les
infrastructures routières augmenterait
de plus de 4 % le prix du transport pour
les poids lourds les agriculteurs et
professionnels de l'agroalimentaire
yvelinois soutiennent dans un premier
temps la fronde la mesure est suspendu
en novembre les qui taxent grossi un peu
plus la gronde sociale la filière
équestre refusent la hausse de la tva de
7 à 20 % en janvier dans les yvelines un
département qui comprend le plus de
licenciés en france de nombreuses
mobilisations sont organisés un
collectif se crée la horde 78 elle
rassemble professionnels amateurs
éleveurs cavaliers ou encore enseignants
enfin les agriculteurs dénoncent une sur
fiscalisation et la redistribution des
aides européennes en faveur de l'élevage
en vambre d'importants blocages sans
mise en place dans le département
heureusement les yvelines reste un
département très dynamiques
économiquement quelques entreprises ont
d'ailleurs affiché un beau parcours la
société carmat tu dévoiles en mai
dernier ce coeur artificiel
totalement implantable est conçu à
vélizy une première applaudi
internationalement en décembre ce choeur
est implanté avec succès sur un patient
de 75 ans souffrant d'une insuffisance
cardiaque la société s'envole en bourse
akka technologies a remporté le grand
prix national de l'ingénierie 2013 avec
son prototype links and go il s'agit
d'une voiture électrique est automatique
qui peut se garer toute seule conducteur
et passager se font face et peuvent sur
cet écran géant visualiser la route
regarder un film ou encore aller sur les
réseaux sociaux marie-josée chevalier
pharmacienne de bouafles a quant à elle
fait la une des journaux pour avoir
lancé l'un des premiers sites internet
de vente de médicaments depuis le 12
juillet la loi autorise les pharmacies à
vendre une partie de leurs produits sur
la toile sont autorisés 4000 médicaments
ne nécessitant pas d'ordonnancé
cette pharmacienne a déposé le nom de
domaine en 1997 un vrai est en avance
elle reçoit de 27 à 38 visites par mois
les grands groupes aussi comptent bien
enregistré des succès dans notre
département nombre d'autres s'y sont
installés et ça continue mercedes france
déménage son siège social à montigny le
bretonneux
les travaux sont encore en cours mille
emplois devraient être créés toujours
des emplois supplémentaires cette fois
du côté du crédit agricole une extension
est prévue pour accueillir 1000 salariés
en plus le chantier a débuté en octobre
à montigny dans le domaine encore des
constructions laisse pas qu'à une école
spécialisée dans les transports de
demain prend forme à montigny elle
devrait accueillir 1500 étudiants
également créateur d'emplois de grands
centres commerciaux teclaw aux
clayes-sous-bois la houlette de luxe one
nation
vingt-quatre mille mètres carrés 112
boutique des marques de luxe qui
proposent dans leurs rayons des
collections passées à prix bradés 5
millions de visiteurs sont attendus
chaque année car et privés ouest un
centre commercial reposant sur le même
concept et qui devait prendre la place
de skywest nevers à lui jamais le jour
un nouveau projet pour ce site devrait
être dévoilé en 2014 enfin à coignières
le forum a fait peau neuve quatre
enseignes ont investi les lieux 2013
laisse maintenant sa place à 2014 et à
de nouvelles actualités économiques
c'est la fin de ce fil et commercy
d'avoir été avec nous je vous donne
rendez vous jeudi prochain même heure
bonne soirée